a big congrats to brian austin green and  sharna burgess  he is an amazing dad i can tell you that  he's one of the best i've ever known or  witnessed that's brian and sharna's new  baby boy clutching dad's finger his name  zane walker green this is so surreal  hours after posting the baby news brian  hit up the last the night premiere in  beverly hills still wearing his hospital  bracelet and giving his co-stars a first  glimpse at the new three-day old  we really took our time we took four or  five dates before we even kissed  sharna brian's former dancing pro and  real-life partner of nearly two years  shared bump dates throughout her  pregnancy this is her first child but  brian's fifth all boys he shares a son  with ex vanessa marcel and three with  megan fox we're told brian and megan  peacefully co-parent and sharna and the  kids get along i love spending time with  the boys and i love having them in my  life that makes me smile